[Music]
dragons are the most sought out and
interesting of all mythical and
fictional monsters they are large in
size and are imbued with very
destructive powers they are reptilian in
appearance and have been in countless
cultural folklore and also movies games
and books they are the go-to creatures
to be set up as the unbeatable foe for
any hero but out of all that the most
distinguishable aspect of this is their
dragon breath no not the smelly breath
of the homeless drummer living in the
streets they mostly have five breaths
that can incinerate almost anything in
their parts and that's the topic of the
day the 10 most powerful fictional
dragon breaths number 10 the bull dragon
the bull dragon is a highly evolved big
fierce dangerous and prehistoric reptile
which served as the main antagonist of
the 2002 film rain of fire so the
dragons in rain of fire are large
four-limbed creatures with glands in
their mouths capable of being ignited to
produce fire and the liquid in this
gland produces also seems to have the
potential to harm the eyes of any human
it comes into contact with there are a
number of both females but only one
powerful male dragon called the bull
dragon the fire breath is the dragon's
primary weapon and very effective and
can be extremely devastating he produces
this flame via chemicals that when mixed
together proves highly combustible he
also has napalm breath which is a very
powerful close-range weapon the napalm
breath shoots out a straight stream of
fired extremely fast which can be
devastating at close range overall the
bull dragon's fire breath is on number
10 rank for its capability to set a fire
the humans shelter but not being able to
penetrate closed doors number 9 smog
next on a list comes mob who was a
firedrake of the Third Age and
considered to be the last great dragon
to exist in middle-earth in the movie
The Hobbit he was drawn towards the
enormous wealth amassed by the dwarves
of the Lonely Mountain during the reign
of a particular King roar and then he
laid waste to the neighboring city of
and captured Erebor the Lonely Mountain
and in the process he dressed of the
surviving dwarves into exile there he
laid in slumber for 171 years being a
fully grown dragon smart was both
massive and powerful possessing physical
strength capable of crushing stone with
ease has seen by his attack on a Lonely
Mountain he also had the ability to
breathe streams of searing hot flame
from his mouth some comments in The
Hobbit imply that his entire body was
imbued with fire smarts fire could
restart the forges of the dwarves melt
steel and destroy an entire small town
called s Gareth with ease number 8
Valyrian / drogue on the next entry is
dragged on and he is one of the three
dragons born in the Red Waste lands
beyond Lazar along with his brothers
Rhaegar and Viserion he is named after
Daenerys Stormborn slate husband Khal
Drogo he can be distinguished by his
black and red colored scales and the red
black wings the reason why we included
Valyrian alongside dragons that he is
widely believed to be the reincarnation
of balerion the black dread the biggest
dragon in the game of Thrones universe
most of his scales are black shadowing
red ones then run down his back and neck
his eyes are orange rep and dragon has
grown to be the size of a large whale he
has an immensely physical strength and
can spit destructive streams of fire he
was able to destroy an entire city the
one being King's Landing with an
unstoppable fire breath his breath was
also able to melt steel
as seen when he took down the iron
throne number 7 the B wildebeest the
first entry from the Dragons franchise
be wildebeests are incredibly massive
spiky dragons with a pair of massive
tusks like horns protruding from the
sides of their heads and huge multiple
wings the front side of their bodies are
covered with spikes along with two lines
of spikes running along the islets
giving an impression of eyebrows
protrusions from the back of their heads
form frills being the largest Dragons
known be Willoughby's possess unmatched
strength and raw power IV Willoughby's
most notable and fear ability is to
burst streams of ice turning water on
contact it does this by sucking up and
ingesting masses of water from the sea
and storing it in the goddess doubt its
neck
this ice glass is extremely powerful and
can create immense glacial explosions on
contact that can destroy and penetrate
any artificial structures with ease
this species icy breath could destroy
multiple ships in a single burst and
also turn birth into an icy crystal
landscape number six vie Siri on another
one from Game of Thrones the Sirian was
one of the three dragons born in the
wastelands beyond Lazar
along with Drogo and Rhaegar he was
named after Daenerys Targaryen elder
brother Viserys he could be
distinguished by his cream and gold
coloured scales and the red orange wings
eventually he became an ice dragon and
it is in this form that he is included
in the list being an undead dragon that
was under the knight Kings control he
could not be killed unlike his living
version he can spit blue fire powerful
enough to demolish a part of the wall
with a single breath and given the
immensely powerful magic place in order
to create the 800 foot tall wall the
fact that his blue fire breaths
destroyed it with ease easily place him
under this number six spot on this list
but we were not able to see him destroy
cities or towns with it but it is easily
possible for him to do so number five
the Red Death the Red Death is a
gigantic dragon her head is heavily
armed with a nasal horn a coral shaped
frill with jaws that a lineup with huge
salt like teeth the Red Death possesses
three pairs of eyes have gifts at little
or no blind spot her coloration is
mainly blue with an orange underside and
its enormous body spots coral like
spines as well as red spikes that gives
this dragon its name despite her
gargantuan size the wings of the Red
Death can give it the ability of flight
the red deaths methane-based flame Jets
are enormous and are powerful enough to
take down an entire fleet of Viking
ships in just one breath the blazing
torrents that are able to create huge
amounts of black smoke which also makes
them resemble volcanic pyroclastic flows
whether the fire breath could beat the
wildebeest icy breath is unknown but
given the fact that it can destroy an
entire fleet with ease it can easily
annihilate cities with ease
number 4 dragon storm the next entry is
a strange one
is an alien living metal dragon dragon
storm is a BC tree headed dragon mighty
gesture form of the legendary 12
Guardian Knights who opposed Quintessa
at other times dragons Thomas instead
form from dragon occurs and storm rain
or he is a single non combining bot when
dragon storm is formed for the first
time in transformers the last night
movie storm rain is not needed to become
a part of him
during the last part of the last night
movie dragon storm form from the
constituent transformers and when tonne
falls into battle he was able to chase
down and shoot down a couple of
Decepticon fighter aircraft using
nothing but his dragon breath even if he
wasn't seen to cause much destruction
but the fact that his dragon breaths
could destroy alien aircraft possibly
made of dense alloys it's quite
impressive and that is why his dragon
breath is ranked higher on this list
than the others number 3 and Callaghan
the only entry from Burke's namely the
scenario Yan and Callaghan also known as
and Callaghan the black was the greatest
of all wicked dragons he was bred by
Morgoth during the first age and was the
largest dragon to have ever existed in
middle-earth and quite possibly in
fiction his appearance in history was
restricted to the war of Wrath and
Callaghan size is not specified but must
have been colossal due to the
destruction of the towers of tangora
dream which were volcanic mountains when
he fell on them he is the largest dragon
to have ever lived and the greatest of
all wing and Dragons as said before the
fire he breathed was hotter than most
other dragons and during the war frat he
burst out of the volcano and terrified
the hosts of the Valor making them
retreat and consider ending the war
because of the immense casualties caused
by and elegans devastating fire and
given that the valor and near
all-powerful his firepower would have
been off the charts in order to drive
them away
number 2 death wing this entry is from
the game World of Warcraft death swing
the destroyer formerly known as
Neltharion the earth water he was one of
the five dragon aspects and the leader
of the Black Dragonflight
ages ago Neltharion was empowered by the
pantheon with dominion over the earth
and deep places of Azeroth he later
became the aspect of death and one of
the greatest terrors of the known world
he was perhaps the most powerful servant
of the old gods Deathwing has control
over the land and his fathoms including
lava his main attack and that of his
dragon flights is to use his breath as a
cannon of lava as seen in the trailer of
World of Warcraft Cataclysm he was able
to incinerate and set everything on fire
by his mere presence and wings his fire
is so destructive that it was able to
melt stones and any metal in the
vicinity his breath is equally powerful
and he was able to destroy an entire
kingdom called storm win number one King
Ghidorah King Ghidorah is a large tree
headed dragon women like guide you with
two large wings and two tails he is
usually shown to be bigger than Godzilla
in size the origins of King Ghidorah
vary from film to film but he's almost
often depicted as being an otherworldly
creature of malicious intent in the
Showa era Ghidorah is an evil space
monster responsible for wiping out all
life on many planets across the universe
it's just one of his targets but he is
usually a postman Godzilla as well as
other monsters like Mothra and Rodan
King Ghidorah signature attack is his
ability to spit powerful gravity beams
from his three heads
kingi doors gravity beams can cinch
Godzilla's skin and level entire city
blocks in one hit the gravity beams are
beams of concentrated gravity particles
fight out into a beam of gravity the
standard gravity beam is usually a
bright yellow glowing color and it is
with this power that Ghidorah was able
to subdue and destroy entire worlds
before coming to earth his dragon breath
is the strangest and the most unique of
all others on his list and also the most
powerful and with this we come to the
end of the list be sure to LIKE share
and subscribe to this channel for more
videos like these